a New York Times bombshell about Brett
Kavanaugh bus president Trump reacting
just minutes ago the paper now being
accused of smearing the Supreme Court
justice it comes after a weekend story
about a new sexual assault allegation
from Cavanaugh's college days at times
forced to make a major revision after
leaving out key facts including that the
accuser declined to be interviewed and
that friends say she doesn't even recall
the alleged incident twenty twenty
Democrats immediately jumping on the
unverified claim to demand Kavanagh be
impeached president Trump responding by
defending Kavanagh and attacking The
Times watch another terrible mistake
it's it's a shame that a thing like that
could happen I see they're making a big
correction today they've just announced
as a correction but to do that about a
Supreme Court justice is a terrible
thing it's a false accusation whatever
happened with the New York Times I mean
I can tell you personally they never
checked they never do we used to have a
thing called fact-checking they don't do
fact-checking anymore they used to call
and say what about this what about that
how can they do a thing like that and
destroy somebody's life I mean they're
destroying lives and it's fake news it
just make news but it's a very fair
question I mean they have to be very
embarrassed but much more importantly
what they do is wrong are they do it all
the time alright Greg it's like the New
York Times keeps stepping on a rake I
don't see the problem here they just
left that one minor detail right it's
like it's a command a front page that
says you know major stock market crash
and then four pages later it says well
actually the stock market went up ten
points
everything we just said was a complete
and utter lie most editors and writers
are liberal we know that but most good
editors will operate with a conservative
filter so that's so they don't get
compromised by their own biases so they
know that their liberal and they don't
want it but if they if they don't check
themselves then they might allow a
corrupt product to go through that no
longer exists for the New York Times so
their filter is gone so anything goes
through we I think we should be pretty
grateful that there are people like
Molly Hemingway that are out there
because like I didn't like
didn't spend the time this weekend
reading a book I didn't spend the time
chasing down this crap yeah but but but
but if one person or two people weren't
paying attention if Molly Hemingway
hadn't pointed this out that the that
the main person the victim could not
verify the actual accusation the time
should not have copped to this they
would not have had the correct
correction they're only doing it because
they got caught and that raises that a
really big question how many stories did
they get away with because nobody was
paying attention I would say almost all
of the stories New York Times have done
are inaccurate and wrong that's why
that's how I see it now they're all
wrong no because I've been you know this
day and a night the one you know this
tube Jessie you will you may be that
when you become the object of a story oh
yeah that's when you know stuff is left
out that's true it's true it's but I
didn't think it was fair to say
everything they write well yeah but it
happened to me in New Times had written
stuff about me years ago and I just kind
of laughed it off because it's like well
you can't get it all right now you know
they get it all wrong they actually did
a story on me and they put the wrong
person's picture they did that did it
work in your favor I do agree with you
Greg and here's why I disagree with you
a little bit I think they made the
mistake on purpose right I think they
purposely left this out and then the day
later say oh you know we'll add that in
later because that's their agenda they
have talented people there and it's a
great company but they have an agenda
and the agenda right now is to sell
newspapers and attack the President of
the United States I have a new way I
digest these mainstream media attacks
now on would you like to hear absolutely
I wait 24 hours and then the bombshell
turns out to be a bust because even if
just the last month we've had this story
we've had the CNN Russia story we've had
the lawrence o'donnell russell story and
then we've had the trump term berry
resort story all of those turned out to
be not what they were presented at take
a reverse shrinky dink well i don't know
what that is
the New York Times stories or a verse
rinky-dink rinky-dink you know they
expand in this case the expanding that a
streak was that it's a toy in the 70s
yeah
all right well either way even in jail a
bunch of shrinking even Morning Joe
criticized the New York Times here and
just look at the Cavanaugh accusations
in the beginning there were no
corroborating witnesses and the one
woman who says she was there she says
she wasn't there and she doesn't even
believe Blasio for this is investigated
by the Senate investigated by the FBI
and then this news story about Yale
think about how ridiculous this sounds
he had something out mm-hmm at a party
and someone pushed the into someone else
and there's no remember there's no
witnesses and the one person who heard
about it worked as a Clinton defense
lawyer I mean come on
it's preposterous and it just shows how
bankrupt the left out is because all
they do is they smear against racism
they smear against Russia and they smear
against rape and corrections should be
rare right but we have a rash of them I
don't think we have any rash I think in
fact I don't think this is about the New
York Times to my mind this is about the
FBI and the Senate I mean obviously
during the hearings now a year ago Dana
we were promised when Kavanaugh was
confirmed that the FBI looked in
especially to the Kristine Bosley Ford
allegations and that there was nothing
that you could not refute what the what
justice Cavanaugh had said and it would
be unfair to him as the unfair to
anybody to just allow some you know
scurrilous allegation to stand and the
FBI couldn't find any evidence to back
up what Ford was saying that's what way
although she gave good testimony but now
we know that they did not because we
have senator Coons saying he sent them a
letter about this latest allegation and
the allegation by the way still stands
by this man who attended Yale with
Cavanaugh this is the guy that works
reference no this is a guy who his back
star is with a partnership for public
service but he it's a nonpartisan group
but he the one who made this allegation
back then Coons senator Kuhn says he
sent this allegation to the FBI but
we've never heard a the FBI apparently
did not investigate it and then the
thing is investigate something when they
somebody that said that this guy says it
happened to this woman and Emily
yeah the sorts of the
elevations were were seen it's very
flimsy Brian York runs it down of the
seven sources all of them heard it from
each other
secondhand well that's the point is that
if you if you had investigation we would
know but there was no investigation so
it comes out in this book by the way
this is an LA Times reporter has a
similar thing going and the people say
well yeah they heard it from each other
max Dyer is saying yeah I stand by it
but we don't the the key part and this
is where the New York Times did make an
error was that they emitted key
information that this woman has declined
to be interviewed and says to her
friends that she doesn't remember them
so then if that's the case Emily how
does the FBI investigate something that
the woman says she doesn't recall even
happened or at what point do you say
okay the investigation is complete
because there is no corroborating
evidence other than me citing that
person aide told person B the same thing
that I'm hearing from person a that does
not a corroboration make my issue with
this it's to me there's that there's the
news aspect the New York Times there's
the publication and there's the delivery
right because remember how many tweets
are they had to delete late right so
they published and omitted not just key
information but literally fundamental
information that poked holes in it this
is like when was it in the 40s or 50s
when they were broadcasting war of the
world on the radio and they didn't say
this is fiction this is fiction so
people were freaking out thinking that
aliens were attacking it goes to your
point earlier so they omit the
fundamental information that this is not
corroborated this is an allegation from
the prior then they do it in a delivery
which says oh it's harmless fun and have
to retract that just like their 9/11
tweet and then we have on the side a
bunch of twenty20 Democratic candidates
who say they are all for criminal
justice reform and yet our plane judge
jury and executioner and calmly Harris
is saying you lied and your testimony
should be retracted and you all should
be impeached the Democratic Party to me
if this has continued to if they
continue to pursue this they are
shooting themselves in the foot and it
is themselves that they are destroying
well I don't think it's reckless fun as
you say the New York Times I think that
they have a guy max there who's on the
record saying has happened and guess
what
heard it Deborah Deborah Ramirez made a
similar allegation that was again
dismissed during the course of the
hearings now we're thinking hey this
sounds a lot like what we heard before
in the other college no no let's just
fit New York Times got caught with their
pants down how ironic well I somebody
else might have to not that's the
problem all right